So now we have we know a little bit about probably like we
know the fundamentals of probability.
This we have introduced ourselves to the this thing
called probability this number that is between 0
and 1 now. Let's introduce ourselves to the most important
component in all of statistics and probability the random
variable.
Okay.
This is where knowing those key terms is going to
help us.
understand this concept of random variable
Okay, I'm gonna you will see the notation.
And then rotation will help you understand what this thing
is.
first of all
the word variable
in random variable
is
Is a misnomer.
I don't know how many of you have experience with Statistics and probability but
Random variable is not really a variable in the mathematical
sense. It's really a function.
I'll explain later on.
Okay, but
it's important for me to point out because
this variable is
written with an uppercase letter
What is in mathematics variables are
written in lowercase letters?
and usually the letters at the end of the alphabet like X Y and
Z let X be equals to five like why because the three but
there's a reason why the random variable
Is a capital letter?
But anyway one at a time, let's consider
an experiment. What's an experiment?
For being a coin rolling a dice.
That kind of thing.
Where seeds in a flight are aside customers automatically
and randomly.
so we have an algorithm in your on the
on the website
Here, for example, we have Emirates airlines in the
UAE. You're on Emirates Airlines and you want to book a
business
business class flight to let's say,
New York.
And let's say you're not particularly about your seating.
You don't care whether it's a what would be business class is
not the best example, let's go with economy.
You can't choose between ilc or
window seat and you don't care about that's a short
flight. And you say I don't really have time to worry about what I'm
seated. Just give me a chair. So the algorithm will assign
a seat for you.
Okay, we're getting closer to understanding what random battery was.
This is called I believe piecewise notation.
so t
this thing we call a variable will take on a value 0
if this seat has already been assigned.
And one if the seat has not been assigned.
Okay.
You see random variable is going to be.
a table
and there are two things that go into this table. This is very important for you to know
from now from from the beginning the table will
have two things values that a random variable can take
and the probability of Any Given
value.
So the random variable will take a value 0
if the seat has been assigned which means you have to go to another
seat and one if it's vacant.
Let's say you have a seat with this ID.
If it has been assigned.
And you try to look up that seat number
in the random variable. This is the notation you will use.
And it's value will be zero.
Perhaps you can see why I'm saying why I said the random variable is
not really a function. It's not really
variable. It's more of a function.
The notation is giving away.
and of course if a seat
is available.
Like you pass in this number.
you get
one so if this if a seat
with this ID is not available you get 0
If it is a if it's not available if it's vacant one
and you keep on going for every other seat that you have.
And it will be 0 1 0 1 in the random variable.
Here's another word. I want you to be familiar with the word Bernoulli.
Remember I told you trials.
Which are special kind of experiments what the outcome
is either one or two is called a Bernoulli.
Bernoulli well to Bernie Lee trial and
if you have a random variable, well the outcomes can
only be one or zero or success and failure or broken and
not broken assigned another side what
we have two can two possible outcomes. We call
that a Bernoulli random variable.